we have new polling and it is it is
remarkable
it has been 15 years since americans
were as optimistic about the future of
the country as they are today
two new polls again confirm some things
that we already knew
americans largely approve of joe biden's
performance as president so far
but the polls were also asking about
american optimism more generally
and an abc ipsos poll finds that almost
two-thirds of americans
are optimistic about the next year
americans have not been this
optimistic about the year to come since
2006
per the same abc poll a second poll
released by yahoo news and yougov finds
that
57 percent of the country approves of
joe biden's handling of the pandemic
when asked if biden's performance was
better worse or the same than expected
the plurality 39 said biden's doing even
better than expected
28 said worse 24 said about what we
expected
and overall joe biden has a 54 approval
rating now
you and i might see that and say 54.
that's not that's not so good that's not
a very high number uh remember that
donald trump never hit 50 percent even
on a single day
of his presidency and was plagued by
approval
in the 30s for the most part and even 29
when he left office so this this is a
change for sure
now in terms of the country being
divided
this is this is interesting and not
great numbers for joe biden
um 28 of americans believe that the
country
is more divided since joe biden took
office
23 percent believe it is uh i'm sorry 23
say more divided 28 say less divided
um that is interesting because
everybody's blaming biden the people
that think the country is more united
think it's more united because of joe
biden the people that think the country
is more divided
also think it's more divided because of
joe biden but
what's clear is that overall politics
has become a lot more boring
and people seem to be okay with that now
fascinatingly
there was the assumption that because
things would be boring under joe biden
shows like the david pakman show
wouldn't do well in fact there were
gleeful trump is saying
david when trump is gone your show will
be circling the drain which is a phrase
we've been hearing for 15 years
we keep growing but put that aside for a
second i assumed
we would we would see a decline in
viewership corporate media has seen a
big decline in viewership since trump
has left
but then something i really don't
understand happened because i was
prepared for like a full year of really
things being pretty slow in late march
then early april mid-april april just
finished
the numbers came that back very strongly
there were no biden scandals nothing in
the biden administration even coming
close to the insanity of the trump white
house
and yet that dip we saw that we see
after every election
in january and february and early march
it's almost completely recovered we were
back up to 30 million views
in april uh 12 million views on facebook
these are like 2020 numbers once again
so i'm curious what you think is going
on
because things are kind of boring in a
sort of uh salacious
uh from a salacious evaluation type
standpoint
tv networks are reporting significantly
lower ratings trump no doubt was good
for ratings and yet we're
almost back to where we were in december
which was a record month not all the way
maybe 85 percent of the way there
if you look at what did best in april
there's some trump stuff in there
that's left over that he's still doing
things but it's a lot of other things
clips about uh right-wingers who just
call into the show to talk to me did
really well
the matt gates scandal got a lot of
attention critiques of right-wing
media framing did well um reporting on
some of these
corporate scams foxconn and others
coverage of the derek chauvin trial
stories about vaccine conspiracies and
other things at this point there's like
seven or eight different
general areas of content that are doing
very well so something is going on it's
not only that people are
more optimistic than they've been for 15
years they're optimistic but they're
also not
tuning out if it bleeds it leads you
know we know about that
if people are satisfied and complacent
rather than panicked
they tend to watch a lot less news but
yet people are watching almost as much
of the show as they were in december
the most optimistic interpretation i
have
is people recognize that things are
going in the right direction
but realize that if we tune out now and
not pay attention
to what's going on maybe we get trump or
something like him back in 2024.
the real explanation could be anything
i'd be curious to hear from from you
why is most of that election peak
audience
already back let me know your thoughts
you can find me on twitter
deepakman very interested in hearing
from you